mais mes chers amis nous attendons les
résultats après ans partira déjeuner
alors françois xavier a posé la question
de l'islamisme radical
il l'a posée seul mais c'est une
question qui nous est posée à longueur
de réunion y a personne ici
quelle que soit sa région qui puisse
contester qui a une sourde inquiétude en
transe et une colère françois xavier dit
les républicains doivent être la
formation politique qui ne reculera plus
c'est vrai c'est incontestable que la
pensée unique a empêché un certain
nombre d'entre nous sans doute moi comme
les autres de dire de mettre les mots
sur l'exaspération et la colère des
français
simplement françois-xavier le problème
est le suivant comment donner la
certitude que la république de rick ne
reculera plus sans caricaturer notre
position et s'en éloigner du pacte
républicain des français comme vous et
moi qui ont parfaitement le droit de
vivre leur religion
être forts défendre notre identité
sans nous même être des intégristes
c'est la proposition que je vous ferai
demain
mais le sujet est plus complexe qu'on ne
le dit aucune lâcheté aucun ont dit nous
devons parler au nom du peuple français
et le peuple français a besoin que les
points soit mis sur les i et que nos
engagements soient tenus par parenthèse
si je n'avais pas été président de la
république la turquie serait aujourd'hui
membre de l'union européenne
alain juppé s'en souviendra nous avons
été deux à nous y opposer à l'époque de
jacques sion donc c'est une
c'est une affaire françois-xavier très
importante dont nous avons parfaitement
conscience mais il ne s'agit pas
d'abandonner une forme de faiblesse pour
tomber dans une forme de caricature
d'eux sur les collectivités
territoriales bruno est bien ici à cette
tribune des présidents de grandes
collectivités ou des mères les
républicains ne promettront pas aux élus
locaux d'une augmentation des dotations
parce qu'avec la situation va nous
laisser françois lent ça serait mentir
en revanche notre idée c'est de
supprimer tous les accords jospin du
début des années 2000 de réduction du
temps de travail dans la fonction
publique d'autoriser les exécutifs
territoriaux à discuter tant de
travailleurs supplémentaires librement
dans leur collectivité territoriale et à
autoriser tous les élus à embaucher dans
la fonction publique sur des contrats de
cinq ans librement pour pouvoir adapter
votre masse salariale à la situation de
nos finances publiques
enfin mosson renouvellement urbain j'ai
suivi ce qu'avait fait jacques chirac
l'anru c'est 44 milliards d'euros pour
les banlieues
j'aimerais savoir depuis quatre ans ce
qu'a fait monsieur hollande pour les
banlieues
pas un centime pas une initiative pas un
mot ce qui dans nos quartiers ont voté
pour françois hollande
on tue la réponse mais aujourd'hui le
problème pour nous c'est de continuer le
travail que nous faisons sur les
banlieues mais de répondre à
l'humiliation de la ruralité
je le dis je souhaite que les
républicains dans leur projet met comme
priorité un plan marshall pour la
ruralité
ce que nous avons fait il ya quinze ans
pour les quartiers nous devons le faire
demain pour la ruralité qui est dans une
situation d'humiliation et de perte
d'identité très préoccupante pour
l'unité nationale